over the last five years in particular
we've seen cloud gaming evolve to the
point where it really is delivering on
that vision of a Netflix for gaming that
we all like so much
the stars are now line the technology is
now in place and today hundreds and
millions of Gamers can get access to
games through services like GeForce now
and Xbox game pass so we asked ourselves
how could we build a gaming handheld
that was a hundred percent designed for
the cloud
we spent the last two years working
Without Partners tencent Microsoft
Nvidia and more figuring out that
problem we created a product that is
designed from the ground up to enable
Gamers to experience thousands of games
literally in the palm of their hands
today we're excited to officially unveil
the Logitech G
clown gaming handheld
[Applause]
making a cloud gaming handheld that
works flawlessly across multiple
Services requires expertise and Hardware
software and in content to help with
that we partnered with tencent gaming
and I have a quick message from Daniel
Wu from tencent gaming hi I'm excited
today to join you for the launch of the
Logitech G cloud gaming handhelding
a new device co-developed by Logitech
and tencent games
peasant games has been dedicated to
providing exhilarating and diversified
gaming experiences four players around
the world
we understand that both content and
Hardware are vital to achieve our goals
and that's why we partnered with
Logitech G on this amazing device
which we believe will deliver a truly
outstanding gaming experience
we hope it meets your expectations
and we wish you a great time today at
launch Play
thank you all
thank you Daniel
we wanted the gcloud to deliver a simple
to use and Powerful experience for
playing on the cloud
that's both the technology problem and a
really big design challenge
we needed to be very choiceful about the
specifications and really put the user
first
and to tell us more about that design
challenge I'd like to welcome Ahmed
rears up our head of design for Logitech
G
s thank you
I'm really really excited to share what
the team has been working on over the
last two years
so I'm going to unveil this
all right
and here we have the Logitech
cloud
and so
one of the things that's been really
really exciting when we started
designing this is we started thinking
about how do we really design something
that was Cloud first
and when we're thinking about designing
something Cloud first we thought what is
the big idea at the center of this
and for us the big idea was what does it
mean to have instant access to thousands
of games at your fingertips
you have to design a device that has the
flexibility of being able to play on a
sofa or in your bedroom or even in your
backyard
it needs to be something intimate it
needs to be something immediate and it
needs to be something immersive
with Logitech gcloud
play pirate and private and Rain death
on my enemies
kick back kick ass and knock off my
competition in my backyard
fulfill forgotten prophecies slay some
serious beasts and bask in the vast
foils of my conquests
in my kitchen
so get comfortable there's levels to
play I think I'll take the pink
stream a ridiculous amount of games from
XBox and Nvidia GeForce now with
Logitech gcloud
and so with that in mind we thought
immersion is incredibly incredibly
important for gamers and for that reason
we have a seven inch 1080p screen and it
has everything that you need so you
won't miss a single moment in your
gaming because we have the ability to
really design amazing controls and we've
been practicing that with rc40 and our
history with Logitech we thought what
was really cool is we could build
something that was incredibly precise
but also very comfortable and bring that
into a cloud device a handheld
and we know Gamers come in all different
shapes and sizes and needs and so we
wanted to make sure that we had all the
remapping controls available on the
device itself and with our focus on the
cloud we didn't need to worry about
overheating or fans or a massive hard
drive we were just able to make
something that was much lighter than
anything else out there so it just sort
of floats and you know it's incredibly
thin
and it's great that it's so comfortable
because it comes with 12 hours of
battery life enough to go through any of
those long gaming sessions and so you
can connect it with a 3.5 millimeter
Jack Bluetooth and of course Wi-Fi you
can extend the storage and we even added
fast charging that can get you from zero
to fully charged in 2.5 hours
and we know that while we are focused on
streaming people also like to play from
devices they're streaming from their
home so we also built in optimizing for
Xbox Remote Play and steam link right
from the device
and we wanted to not limit the device in
any way so we want to give choice to our
Gamers so under the hood you have a
fully functioning Android tablet and
direct access to the Google Play Store
it's your device you can do whatever you
want with it you know with this device
we were really working closely with Xbox
and Nvidia and really sharing the dream
of bringing all these games to your
fingertips
so with that I'd like to First announce
our partner with Xbox
Catherine she's going to join us by a
video
hello I'm Catherine glockstein vice
president of Xbox cloud gaming at
Microsoft I'm excited to be with you at
today's event
at Xbox it's our mission to bring the
joy and community of gaming to people
around the world by enabling you to play
the games you want with the people you
want any way you want we have built Xbox
for all kinds of players who all want to
play together to build a community and
most importantly to have fun it all
starts with Xbox game pass a gaming
membership which allows you the freedom
to discover and play a curated library
of hundreds of high quality games this
includes new titles from Xbox game
studios in Bethesda such as death Loop
which just arrived on Game Pass we also
work with our Global game creator
Partners to add fan favorites and Indie
hits to the Game Pass library at the
heart of what we do is provide choice so
everyone can find their next favorite
game
our focus on Choice goes beyond just
content we're also providing choice in
where and how you play by making Xbox
available on multiple devices using the
cloud with Xbox cloud gaming included
with Xbox game pass ultimate we're
making it easier than ever to play
console games in new ways from phones
and tablets to multiple generations of
consoles and even more devices with a
screen
it's as easy as clicking and playing
with whatever device is in front of you
and as we look ahead we want to make it
even easier for people to play by making
Xbox cloud gaming available on new
devices
So today we're here to celebrate with
Logitech on their upcoming launch of the
Logitech gcloud which we're happy to
announce will feature Xbox cloud gaming
pinned right to your home screen with
the gcloud you'll be able to stream Xbox
games from the game past library or play
fortnite for free with no Game Pass
membership required simply access Xbox
cloud gaming directly from the gcloud
launcher Straight Out of the Box
it has been wonderful to see the growth
of cloud gaming over the years and we're
really thrilled that Logitech is
investing in a cloud gaming device that
will Delight players with Xbox games
and next I'd like to welcome from Nvidia
Richard
[Applause]
thanks Riaz
G-Force is the largest most powerful
gaming platform and it's the engine that
drives GeForce now
for almost a decade we've been working
hard to develop GeForce now into the
cloud gaming platform you see today
offering Gamers the ability
to enjoy high quality PC gaming
typically reserved only for battle
station gamers
across many devices even those that
aren't game ready
GeForce now allows players to connect to
the most popular PC game stores
including steam epic Ubisoft Electronic
Arts tap into their libraries of games
and stream them
direct from the cloud as a high
performance gaming rig that means high
resolution High frame rates
low latency
and settings turned up to Max
cinematic visuals with RTX turned on
and it's essentially a really high
performance GeForce PC gaming rig in the
cloud
we're adding new games to the platform
every Thursday with GeForce now
Thursdays so in addition to top PC games
like cyberpunk 2077
Apex Legends
Dying Light 2. we also have over a
hundred free to play games on the
service like fortnite gention impact
destiny 2. and as well as that we're
bringing new games to the platform so
we've announced still Rising isozo
little Orpheus
metal helsinger just this week
as well as extending the games on our
platform
we're really excited to be able to
extend the service and have a
collaboration with Logitech G
to extend our platform coverage
with the addition of their gcloud device
which is a really exciting gaming
handheld that's been optimized for
GeForce now ensuring that our members
get the same experience on their device
thank you
thanks Richard
thanks very much
yeah we're very very excited we can't
wait to get the product out to Gamers
around the world we're going to be
starting first in North America on
October 17th and we'll be rolling out
from there
so as you can see we're really deeply
passionate about play and you know it's
why we brought you all together here at
our first ever Logie play event we hope
that you've seen that with the eight
products that we announced today
that we've we take play very seriously
and we're committed to creating products
and experiences for gamers all Gamers on
a variety of platforms uh audience types
and use cases
our commitment to design technology and
Innovation goes Way Beyond just speeds
and feeds we actually really spent a lot
of our time thinking and understanding
from the gamer first what is it that
they want what are their motivations and
how can we uniquely address them it's
you the gamer that ultimately really
inspires us and and fuels us to go and
create new possibilities of play
I'd like at this point to ask Brack and
Daryl to come back up and share some
remarks thank you Peter
[Applause]